let's talk about black lives matter we
have this from ABC News BLM Chicago
backs Palestine after Hamas Terror
invasion of Israel and this is causing a
major backlash and uh tons of Democrats
are now disavowing black lives matter
this is going to be a huge break in the
culture War because now you've got
Democrats who are like wait a minute you
mean the far-left we've supported want
Israelis to be killed yeah take a look
at this tweet this is an archive it was
deleted from BLM Chicago it says that is
all that is it and it says I stand with
Palestine and it's a it's a paraglider
with a Palestinian flag the paragliders
are the ones who went into the music
festival and started killing civilians
they did more than just kill they they
right kidnapped rap raped kidnapped yeah
uh children and so this is this is an
image explicitly supporting the tactic
of targeting
civilians look man we we sit here and we
complain about war all day and when the
US has collateral damage you complain
about it we support Julian Assange he
released collateral murder we see we we
see these these war crimes we criticize
Obama we criticize Trump killing
civilians is wrong Israel kills
civilians who say it's wrong the the
issue however is in the instance of
Israel often times what they're saying
is they've built a weapons Depot and a
military base under a hospital we've
given them a warning and we're going to
take it out I say okay do I take
Israel's word for it well the one thing
I can say is Israel at least is saying
that much we are trying to avoid killing
civilians well okay I don't trust
governments right everyone's got an
agenda but I can accept that you then
have Barack Obama's ridiculous nonsense
excuse for killing an American citizen
in Yemen they've never answered for and
that's evil but this is overtly
celebrating the tactic of targeting
civilians intentionally yeah you know
that's black lives matter Max Blumenthal
he was on last night and he said that
these guys were paratrooping into to hit
a military Target and landed next to the
Target in the music festival and it was
an attack of opportunity as opposed to a
target a target of opportunity I don't
know if it really I don't know how much
matters wa wait like I mean if he's
being factual he's being factual yes but
in terms of of celebrating it still I
mean that image now is still the image
of attacking civilians at a music
festival it's not a you know the wind
blew the wrong way we actually meant
when they made this image they knew what
they were saying ex and they kept it up
for hours it wasn't like oops Del 20,000
comments or something before they they
decided someone decided to take it down
I want to be care of is you know people
were being critical of Max yesterday
they're like oh I can't believe he would
downplay no no no hold on if it is a
fact that that Hamas was intending to
Target military bases that would make
sense they say we want to hit military
bases and then as they're coming through
the sky they say hey look civilians
let's get them because it is a known
tactic to Target civilians to use his
bargaining chips against Israel Max said
all that too those are facts accept them
it it proves definitively or I should
say a journalist with a prob with with a
pro Palestine bias explicitly told us
their strategy is Target civilians why
why why would they attack an Israeli
military base on parag I mean the IDF is
scary you're not going to barge in well
what he was saying is that it caught him
off guard and it was humiliating it was
quiet off radar cuz it's they're so low
to the ground and no heat probably yeah
I what what I find fascinating in the
whole thing is that there are many
people prominent individuals many who
are very critical of Israel PL saying
that Israel knew this was coming and let
it happen and then you have Max of all
people who is you know much more opposed
to Israel's actions being like no
there's no way Israel knew in advance
they were humiliated by this Hamas was
targeting the mil the military bases and
the music festival was nearby and so it
became a target of opportunity for them
because it is a known tactic they use
like wow but that wasn't the only place
that was attacked right they went to a
bunch of villages a bunch of beaches
anywhere makes think that their primary
target was take out the military
perimeter and then with a secondary
Target of get as many civilians as you
can it's evil and and and this is the
this is the problem right I don't like
War I don't like the conflict I don't
like hearing about children dying in
Gaza all these tweets coming out the far
left saying oh look all these innocent
civilians I'm like yeah it's all bad
it's all bad dude but
yo ask I I can ask this question of
anyone and you're going to get the same
answer the pro the pro Palestine side
knows what the answer to this question
is and they will try to avoid answering
it what would happen to Israel if they
removed all of the security fencing
around Gaza and said free movement for
all within Gaza into Israel what would
happen oh we know exactly what happened
we watched it happen yeah we watched
watch what happened when they tore the
fences down yeah there there there's no
question about that and so you know you
talk to someone who poor Palestine and
they're going to say well I mean you
know it's like oh we we get it this is
the problem you complain about what
Israel is doing in Gaza but what's the
answer well these people are in their
prison I'm like yeah and if they open
the doors it would be Bloodshed it would
be murder it would be massacres it would
be it would be War War it would be you
know they they we talk a lot of people
talk about 1948 and how it was wrong for
you know Israelis to push Palestinians
off their land and I'm just like it's
War I don't have a good answer for you
man war is bad it sucks but the answer
today is not to just make the war worse
that seems to be what Hamas wants to do
but anyway back to the point like
otherwise we're going to go in circles
back to what black lives matter
represents we also have a a Democratic
Socialist member of Congress he has quit
the DSA and denounced them for their
support of of of all of this who who was
it uh let me let me let me pull up his
name do you guys know his name I had his
Jamal Bowman no was he part of the DSA
Shri here we go we got it Shri thodar
Congressman he renounces he's a uh let's
see proud detroiter yeah from Michigan
Michigan's 13 district and he renounces
his membership in the DSA saying today
I'm officially renouncing my membership
in the DSA after the brutal Terror
attacks in Israel which included the
indiscriminate murder rape and
kidnapping of innocent men women and
children I can no longer associate with
an organization unwilling to call out
Terror in all its forms Sunday's hate
filled and anti-semitic rally in New
York City promoted by the New York DSA
makes it impossible for me to continue
my affiliation I stand with Israel and
its right to defend itself there is no
place for moral equivocation in the face
of unadulterated evil as we have seen
from Hamas I will continue to work
towards the goals that brought me to
Congress in the first place universal
healthcare workers rights strong labor
union equity for communities of color
environmental justice and compassion
immigr my ideals have not changed at all
I strongly believe that ending my associ
with the DSA serves my constituents
interests as they expect me to represent
them by helping to build a better more
just world not faning the Flames of
hatred shout out to Ryan long who put
out a video called the actor doesn't
know whether to support Palestine or
Israel because the fascinating thing is
what we're seeing here with Shri and
there's another story about a bunch of
Harvard students who are being
blacklisted and now they're putting out
letters being like no we don't support
Palestine we're so sorry we're so sorry
the default position for for a lot of
these people was whatever the narrative
is I support whatever popular thing is
black lives matter was current thing we
support it uhoh BLM not just BLM in
Chicago but La came out in defense of
what Hamas did yeah and now if you tweet
in support of BLM you will get canceled
these people don't have convictions
don't have morals and were marching in
lock step with what they thought was the
power structure that meant when
atrocities occurred with on video and we
see innocent people being praed around
murdered kidnapped Etc they ignore that
and say it doesn't matter BLM is popular
thing think about that just I want to
reiterate that because that is that ex
that explains the culture War so well
for all of us we can sit here and be
like man it's really bad when civilians
died no matter who does it right what
Hamas did is horrifying and it's
atrocious we don't want war I'm
skeptical of these videos and these
stories did babies really get beheaded
man this is tough we try to be
reasonable so many actors members of
Congress Harvard students knowing these
videos emerged thought but the left is
in power so I will just agree with
whatever they say and what happened
major backlash big regular people were
like bro you just defended literal
Terror attacks on innocent civilians the
problem with people that are obsessed
with domestic politics and have no idea
what's going on geopolitically you got
to know both and I think in this case
it's important to note that black lives
matter is essentially saying the tacus
are Justified right if you have a
political movement within the or within
the United States that says essentially
using civilians as ponds harming them to
get your political ends is is worth
doing that's a very significant
statement to take right we know the
black Liv matter movements often end in
right riots and violence the fact that
they're lining up behind this kind of
action is something we should all be
extremely wary of yeah they share
violent means to an end philosophy
although right and they're confirming it
on a geopolitical stage now of course
yeah I'm just saying they got passed off
as being this so we're peaceful peaceful
movement and I think Tim's totally right
ultimately you know people don't know
enough about these issues to be able to
say definitively how they feel about it
but they know they're supposed to say
something that's why Ryan Ryan Long's
fun video is so is so funny he knows
he's supposed to take a stance he just
doesn't know what it is because he takes
his cues from everyone around him they
the issue is they don't care that many
of the people who are who are waving BLM
flags and these progress Pride Flags
don't know don't care all they're really
saying is
I support what we view to be the
cultural and institutional power and so
when the institutional powers do evil
things these people march in lock step
behind them and that's what we talk
about I I've mentioned that the progress
pride flag is is is akin to the Nazi
flag not in that it represents the same
ideology but that it represents people
blindly marching behind what they view
to be power this shattered that and now
people are panicking I love this this
Harvard student organization being like
we never meant this no we're so we we
regret signing this letter in support of
Palestine money cuz we won get our six
figure jobs when we graduate that's
right because now they they're realizing
they're getting canceled right the the
only thing they ever cared about was
looking like they fit in no morals and
no principles but there's also and I
agree with you but there's also I mean
there's this ethos in the white Liber
I'll say white liberal but culturally
white you know the Western liberal I
think you were touching on this too when
they're they're suddenly horrified it's
this mentality and it's so racist I know
that word so overused but it exposes how
racist that they look at people like
Islamic terrorists and it's the same way
they look at inner city violence in
Black communities and they think uh and
they look at Israel like Israel is a
civilized country so we hold them to a
higher moral standard we hold them to
our moral standards these third world
people they're stupid uh they're look at
their skin colors look how they live we
can't expect them to behave how we
behave and they're so oppressed so we
can't you know that we can't Israel is
hold held to a different standard they
cannot behave like this these people
they just don't know any better and we
have to be their custodians we have to
stand up for them
that is the liberal ethos so much and
but then you have the more violent Wing
like BLM and antifa that actually are
like no we want to see dead bodies and
we hate you know these people we want
communism now no it's it's crazy the
polite Progressive class that's exactly
what it is and now they're having this
moral crisis of what side to and I think
that they're going to have a really hard
time reconciling this I think when
people want to do uh the right thing
they but they don't actually think about
the issues they just think about what
their friends are doing they have no
moral compass I mean with these Harvard
students you know if they really
believed in what they said they wouldn't
have backed down nothing nothing should
be worth compromising your values for
but it's not about values it's about
signaling that they have done the right
things it reminds me of you know and
it's it's a terrible comparison to draw
but it reminds me of all of the um
people who suddenly became excited about
various causes like uh after uh the
Parkland shooting all these students who
were suddenly deeply involved in gun
violence and they would hold protests
and whatever else and then they would
get into Elite colleges because they
were signaling that they were behind the
right thing all the time I mean that's
how we got David hog yes
uh and to what end what are what are we
doing to better serve the the values of
the community maybe they really stand by
it but ultimately it was a thing that
they thought would level would help them
get an advantage moving forward yeah of
course like corporations virtue
signaling same thing well this is the
thing we have to do now thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at
timcast.net thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time